s'il n'y avait pas de CMP positif ça
veut dire que les oppositions ne
souhaitent pas qu'il ait un texte sauf
le leur maximalisé que dans ce cas dans
ce cas-là il faut constater le fait que
il y a pas de majorité pour voter le
texte et que la responsabilité en
incombe aux oppositions qui d'un côté
ont maximalisé deux l'ont durci
outrageusement et trois ont refusait de
débattre donc si la CMP n'était pas
conclusif vous ne présenteriez pas le
texte dans l' gverement décidé pas c'est
pas moi déci mais c'est le scénario vous
avez décide qui décide je pense que je
pense je pense que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui ne souhaite ni 493 Souha pas
493 sur ce texte je crois que la
première ministre l'avait dit le le chef
de l'État l'a confirmé hier soir 493 et
que sil y avait un désaccord en CMP jeis
pas pourquoi le texte pourrait
continuer